Bob Barker was 99 years old when he
passed away in 2023 he spent more than
half of those years hosting TV game
shows like The Price is Right but his
offscreen life had twists and turns
you'd never guess like an unexpected
bond with Chuck Norris Bob Barker's
mother Matilda Tarleton Barker was a
school teacher on the rosebud Native
American reservation in Mission South
Dakota and her husband was one4 Sue that
meant Barker himself was 1/8 Sue and
wasn't rolled member of the tribe
spending many of his formative years on
the reservation when he was just 6 years
old his father an electrical power
Foreman died in an accident on the job
in the late 1930s Barker and his mother
relocated to Springfield Missouri but he
never forgot either his native American
or his South dakotan Roots he told the
Argus Leader in 1962 I've always bragged
about being part Indian because they are
a people to be proud of and the Sue were
the greatest warriors of them all Barker
loved talking about his Heritage and
enjoyed telling stories about the Sue's
legendary prowess in battle and their
place in history with his own singular
wit he joked they've been called the
greatest light Cavalry in the history of
man and I have never been on a horse
without falling off as for South Dakota
they're just as proud of him as he was
of them in 1980 Barker was inducted into
the states Hall of Fame in the Arts and
entertainment category growing up in
Missouri Bob Barker always wanted to be
an athlete he had a particular obsession
with one day playing for his hometown's
major league baseball team I wanted to
pitch for the St Louis
Cardinals I was held back by a total
lack of
talent eventually he went to college on
a basketball scholarship but gave up on
his hopes of ever being a pro athlete
over the years though Barker often
talked about his childhood dreams of
playing for the Cardinals and once he
was famous the club took notice in a
2000 interview Barker said that then
Cardinals manager Whitney Herzog invited
the host to come visit the team when he
was in St Louis for a show Herzog gave
Barker his very own Cardinals team
jacket and Team Management also made his
dream come true Barker said the Cardinal
signed me to a contract I get a dollar a
year from the St Louis Cardinals so long
as I do not Pitch many viewers became
familiar with Bob Barker as the host of
the prices right in the80s 90s and
Beyond indeed between 1972 and 2007
there were well over 6,700 episodes of
the famous game show and with just four
exceptions Barker hosted them all but
the truth is Barker was already a
household name when he offered up his
first Showcase in
1972 long before he was telling
contestants they'd gone over with their
bids Barker was the host of another
wildly successful game show Truth or
Consequences where he'd been brought in
to replace outgoing host Jack Bailey in
1956 he continued hosting that show for
18 years during which time he became one
of the most most famous game show hosts
on television it was nice to have you
join us there at home for Truth or
Consequences make it a habit won't you
even before Truth or Consequences Barker
had already made a name for himself
elsewhere prior to his game show days he
appeared on the radio hosting the Bob
Barker show from a studio in birbank
California he also hosted what was then
called an audience participation show
The Story Goes that it was hearing the
Bob Barker show on the radio that
convinced TV producer Ralph Edwards to
select Barker to be the next host of
Truth or consequence
in 1945 Bob Barker married his high
school sweetheart Dorothy Joe Gideon
over the course of Barker's career
Gideon served as a producer writer and
assistant according to the man himself
he owes everything he's ever
accomplished to her he told the
television Academy Foundation without
Dorothy Joe you and I probably would not
be talking she gave me the confidence to
even try to do what I set out to do
despite having no formal training no
experience and no background in
entertainment Gideon believed Barker
could make something of himself in the
industry the host recalled Dorothy Joe
said you do this well enough she said
you're going to be able to do this and
that gave me the confidence to try
Gideon wasn't just Barker's emotional
support though after relocating to
California she left her job as a school
teacher and went to work with Barker
fulltime riding commercial jingles and
much more Barker explained that Gideon
produced and wrote for Barker's radio
shows the couple remained together until
Gideon's death from cancer in
1981 she was uh very bright and totally
devoted embarking on a career in radio
thanks to the support of his wife
Dorothy joean Bob Barker got his first
job out of college at ww PG a radio
station in Palm Beach County Florida
they'd moved there from Springfield
Missouri and he eventually found himself
as an editor and staff announcer at the
station but his favorite moments weren't
the times he was hosting shows on the
air but the holiday season when he
played a Jolly Old Saint Nick Barker
declared with absolute certainty
I was the greatest Santa Claus in the
history of radio I would go over to this
store and put on my Santa Claus outfit
and I lived it I loved it I had more fun
talking with those kids and their
parents in some cases too and we got
lots of laughs we got mail from more
adults than we did kids it was so much
of a joy for Barker that he said he
would have made being Santa Claus his
full-time job if Christmas was year
round when Bob Barker ended his run as
the host of the Price's right it marked
the end of a 35-year era a then record
for the game show circuit he wasn't the
first host of the show but he was key to
its success when it was relaunched as
the new Price is Right in 1972 though
Barker didn't know it at the time
initially signed to what he felt was a
very generous contract he learned later
that the show would not have happened
without him Barker told the television
Academy Foundation creator Mark Goodson
had talked with producer Bud Grant and
Bud Grant had said yes I'll buy that
show for CBS if you get Bob Barker to
host it I didn't know that when we
negotiated if I'd known that Mark could
have been even more generous than he was
but it all worked out for everyone the
prices right went on to become one of
the most successful game shows of all
time and Barker became a TV icon in the
decades after he came to fame Bob Barker
received numerous Awards and honors
including an incredible 19 Daytime Emmy
Awards and a Daytime Emmy Lifetime
Achievement Award he also had a ship
renamed in his honor and it serves a
cause close to his heart a whaling
vessel was Rec christened the Bob Barker
by sea Shepard Global and served as an
anti- wailing ship for 13 years there's
also a street in his old hometown of
Springfield Missouri that boasts the
name Bob Barker Boulevard he received
his star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame
all the way back in
1976 but the honor that meant the most
to him was when CBS renamed Studio 33
Bob Barker studio in
1998 over 35 years of hosting the price
is right there have been many
Unforgettable moments for bar and for
audiences there was the time a
contestant accidentally saw the right
price by mistake or the time a game
malfunctioned outright and gave the
contest in a win when it shouldn't have
but for Bob no moment can compare to the
time a woman got a little too excited
when her name was called and her
bouncing up and down gave everybody a
show after her tube toop couldn't hold
her in Barker has often talked about the
incident as one of his favorite moments
as host of The Price is Right including
his appearance on the Ros O'Donnell show
in 1998 after showing a clip he said
that moment was still the most talked
about in Price's right history despite
happening 20 years earlier she came on
down and they came on out
and even before he was famous as the
host of Truth or Consequences Bob Barker
had already been on TV his first shot on
the small screen was on the game show
your big moment a local talent show that
ran on an NBC affiliate in Los Angeles
for 13 episodes it turns out Barker was
on TV before he even owned one the fact
is Barker broke into TV right when it
was just catching on as an entirely new
medium that fascinated The public's
imagination he said to the television
Academy Foundation I can remember
driving around Hollywood here and there
where people gathered around in front of
the windows at the places where you
could buy television sets watching
television and it just swept the country
it was a radical new way of enjoying
entertainment at home and it grew so
fast that Barker knew his career was
going to be taking a very different
trajectory than he'd first imagined
saying when I first came out here in
1950 I was interested in a national
radio show but by 52 probably I knew
that if I were going to work it was
going to be on television on a national
scale considering that the image most
people have in their minds of Bob Barker
is of a stiff moving older man with
white hair it might raise an eyebrow to
find out that he was actually a trained
martial artist in fact he trained under
one of Hollywood's most famous action
heroes none other than Chuck Norris
himself even more unexpected is that
Barker met Norris years before the
karate m embarked on his own Hollywood
career as it happens Barker bumped into
him when he was on his earlier game show
in an interview with the television
Academy Foundation he said I had Chuck
Norris as a guest on Truth or
Consequences he did a karate
demonstration and I not only had not
done karate I had never seen karate I
was so impressed that I started taking
lessons as Barker recounted he and
chzech Norris formed a yearslong
personal relationship that the host
looked back on fondly the arrangement
also gave him an up close View at
Norris's attempts to make it in Show
Business speaking about their time
together Barker recalled he used to come
over to my house and give me a karate
lesson have a shower and then he'd go
down the street to an acting class that
was before he'd ever even made his first
movie you know I worked with him for
seven or eight years I had a great time
with Chuck according to Barker Norris
didn't go easy on him revealing that in
one session Norris kicked him breaking
two of the hosts ribs though Bob Barker
is one of the most beloved faces in TV
history he wasn't a immune to the
occasional controversy during his many
years on the show numerous allegations
were made against Barker by women
accusing him of wrongful conduct in 1994
model Diane Parkinson brought a lawsuit
against Barker and The Price is Right
claiming she had been coerced into
having a sexual relationship with the
host in order to keep her job while
Barker initially denied their
relationship he later acknowledged
having an affair with Parkinson
according to Barker the pair had engaged
in a consensual relationship while she
was working on the show but insisted
that there was no merit to the charge
that she'd been pressured into it
calling the case frivolous the suit
which Barker said only came about after
he had refused to pay for her silence
was eventually dropped she's no fun at
all Diane Parkinson said she was out of
money and was suffering medical problems
caused by the stress of the case Barker
maintained his innocence and claimed
that if there were any chance she could
win in court the case would never have
been dismissed a year later though
another suit was filed against Barker by
model Holly hollstrom alleging that she
had been fired from the Price's right
for gaining weight Barker filed a
counter claim of slander but the two
sides reached a deal out of court a
well-known and staunch advocate for
animal rights Bob Barker was involved
with numerous Charities over the years
he used his considerable platform to
help protect animals I was just born
with a A Love of Animals in addition to
urging viewers to have their pets spayed
and neutered he refused to allow fur of
any kind as a prize on the show famously
Barker went vegetarian in the late 1970s
an era when that was decidedly not the
norm for big celebrities Barker later
spent $25 million to establish the DJ
andt Foundation which helps clinics spay
and neuter to deter pet euthanization
and donated $5 million to the Sea
Shepard conservation Society Barker
eventually joined Peta but perhaps his
most impactful charitable Endeavor came
from something he didn't do when he
refused to continue hosting the miss us
say pageant over an animal rights issue
Barker claimed that the organization
agreed to discontinue the practice but
in 1988 he went on to host and
discovered that the plan was for the
contestants to walk out on stage in fur
coats and he decided to walk away he
said leaving the pageant was the best
thing to ever happen for the anti- fur
campaign overnight news of his exit from
the pageant was all over television and
suddenly Millions who had never known
about the cause were becoming aware of
it For the First Time The Vision many
have of Bob Barker today is one of a
stately older gentleman with pure white
hair that hair was one of his most
distinguishing features for decades and
set him apart from so many other game
show presenters but for decades before
Barker had sported a swave dark brown de
even well into his 60s that's because
producers of The Price is Right had
Barker dying his hair something which
began to upset the host when he learned
that the product used was tested on
animals and it took a fight with folks
behind the scenes to let him sport his
natural hair color that day finally came
in 1987 arriving on the stage with a
pure white head of hair the crowd roared
with excitement he told talk show host
Ross Schaefer the reaction has been very
positive the girls love this gray hair
since my hair became gray there's just
not enough of me to go around Barker
even claimed in a Los Angeles Times
interview in 1990 that ratings actually
went up after his hair went white during
his time on the prices right Bob Barker
often talked about how much he loved
making the show saying that he'd host
for as long as it was fun he continued
hosting for nearly 20 more years before
he finally spun the showcase showdown
wheel for the last time as the regular
host in 2007 believe it or not though he
almost said goodbye 7 years earlier in
an interview with the television Academy
in 2000 he revealed I thoroughly enjoy
what I do or I would have retired long
ago but this is all I've ever done I was
going to quit this year the show was
going beautifully the ratings are
terrific I'm doing as well as I've ever
done I think I should go out on top I
shouldn't stay too long and so I was
going to retire this year thankfully for
his millions of fans the network
wouldn't let him go they made him an
offer he couldn't refuse and Barker
resigned for another year ultimately
adding another six seasons to his resume
after that they say records are made to
be broken and TV records are no
exception for a long while it was Johnny
Carson who held the seemingly unbeatable
record for continuous performances on
the same network television show then in
2002 Along Came Bob Barker who one up
the late night legend by host ing the
prices right for 29 years 7 months and
22 days retiring officially in 2007 he'd
continueed to hold the record for
another seven years until longtime
Jeopardy host Alex tbec took his crown
in 2014 tbec hosted his own show right
up until his death in 2020 with his
final episodes airing a year later by
2023 the new record holder was Pat sjac
host of Wheel of Fortune who has hosted
over an ipping
7,700 episodes across four decades Bob
Barker was known for his amiable
personality and joal wit perhaps even as
one of the happiest men in Hollywood he
was so hard to make Angry that David
Letterman poked fun at his famously
upbeat attitude with a top 10 list of
things that make Bob Barker angry and
the number one thing that makes Bob
Barker
angry recent allegations that I'm fixed
but there was one person who really did
draw Barker's eye and it's probably the
last person you'd ever expect Golden
Girl star Betty White the feud between
the two celebs went down back in 2009
two years after Barker had retired from
the Price's right now focused almost
entirely on his animal advocacy Barker
was involved in the very public fight to
get an elephant in the LA Zoo released
into a sanctuary but on the other side
was white a proponent of the zoo who
feared it would mean the end of the zoo
industry which itself helps raise
awareness of the plight of animals
eventually the battle between the former
Network stars got heated with Barker
rumored to have said he wouldn't attend
the ceremony for his own Lifetime
Achievement Award at the game show
awards that year if white was in
attendance though neither ever commented
publicly on the spat it's worth noting
that white did not attend in person and
Barker accepted his award on stage
though Bob Barker did indeed retire from
hosting the prices right in 2007 it's
not actually the final time he appeared
on the show in fact it's not even the
last time he hosted in 2009 Barker
popped up in a special guest appearance
walking out during a showcase to PR OTE
his book Priceless Memories emerging to
a thunderous Applause he shook hands
with his replacement Drew Cary before
gifting a copy of his book to every
member of the audience and announcing
that all profits from the sale of the
book would go to his nonprofit DJ andt
Foundation 6 years later as part of the
show's annual April Fool's tradition the
price is Wright introduced Drew Carrey
only for Barker himself to come out on
stage I have never had a welcome like
that Barker at age 92 may have been a
little slower than fans were used to
seeing him but he was as sharp as ever
in his final hosting gig handling the
first bid and pricing game before
handing the Reigns back over to carry
the prices right won Bob Barker critical
Acclaim and countless Awards and turned
him into a cultural icon in addition to
his 19 Emmy wins he was nominated an
additional 20 times during his career
but when perusing a list of all his
honors there's one award that stands out
an MTV movie award not known for his
onscreen acting Barker was a surpr PR
choice for the award which was given for
his bit role in the 1996 Adam Sandler
comedy Happy Gilmore in the film
Sandler's Gilmore gets into a fist fight
with Barker playing himself at a
celebrity golf tournament it's one of
the most memorable moments in the film
and one that has Barker playing
decidedly against type duking it out
with Sandler the fight scene was also
the origin of Sandler's iconic line the
price is wrong for this scene he
and Sandler took home the MTV movie
award for best fight as the host of one
of America's most popular game shows for
35 years you might think that Bob Barker
loved being on the other end of
contestants playing the game knowing the
prizes and all the right answers before
they did according to Barker though
that's not the case at all in an
interview with the television Academy
Foundation Barker said I don't know any
of the prices in fact I don't even know
what the price is going to be and in the
games where the price is the
all-important thing I don't know what
the prices are and I don't particularly
want to as Barker tells it being in the
dark allows him to be a lot more
interactive with his contestants giving
him the opportunity to play along with
them have a lot more fun and even tease
them a bit he said if I knew a
contestant was going to lose that would
be cruel in a way but when I don't know
I can play it to the hilt retiring from
the prices right in 2007 and making his
last hosting appearance in 2015 Bob
Barker spent the last years of his life
out of the public eye popping up mostly
to help promote important animal rights
causes unfortunately the last 20 or so
years of his life were marked with a
number of Health scares beginning with
frequent fights with skin cancer
apparently caused by Decades of tanning
the same year he returned to the Price's
right as guest host Barker also made the
news for taking a fall and injuring his
knee receiving a number of stitches and
being hospitalized as a result less than
2 years later he was back in the
hospital again for another fall and
again a year after that though it wasn't
always easy Barker nevertheless remained
relatively active he was often seen
visiting his wife's grave and was
sometimes photo Red by Paparazzi while
out on leisurely strolls near his Los
Angeles home even during his lifetime
there was never any doubt that the first
line in every obituary for Bob Barker
would be about his role as host of the
Price's right but that's not what Barker
himself really wanted to be remembered
for in 2007 he spoke with interviewer
Terry Marrow of the Knoxville News
Sentinel about his legacy saying I think
that it would be nice if people
remembered me as a guy who loved all
living things and did as much as he
could to make a better world for animals
and also did quite a few television
shows well rest easy Bob because you
just about got your wish while his role
as host of Price's right did indeed top
his memorials following his passing in
August of 2023 it was his work fighting
for animal rights that was often
mentioned right up there with it help
control the pet population have your
pets
[Applause]
Fay